bonjour si je vous fais cette vidéo
assez courtens une petite vidéo entre
deux grosses démission c'est vous pour
vous parler d'une chaîne de vod crise en
ce moment donc c'est du streaming comme
netflix et ça s'appelle médiévale tv
donc comme vous pouvez le deviner
ça parle de moyen-âge j'en ai déjà parlé
un petit peu sur facebook et twitter
mais bon une petite vidéo youtube ça
peut pas faire de mal non plus donc pour
vous représenter projet il s'agit d'une
chaîne qui fonctionnera sur abonnement
et sur laquelle vous aurez de programmes
par semaine une émission est un podcast
donc moi j' aurai une émission où je
parlerai de reconstitution médiévale
mais aussi d'autres intervenants pour
citer les youtuber par exemple vous avez
2 tab est née une go de confession
histoire et marg qui parle de
troubadours et plein de choses bien donc
voilà c'est une chaîne qui est en train
d'essayer de se lancer par une campagne
de financement en fin de prêt abonnement
donc si le sujet vous intéresse vous
aurez tous les liens en fin de vidéo ou
en descriptions et vous pouvez aller
consulter le site
je vous mettrai aussi un lien vers la
petite bande annonce et vous à bouder si
ça vous intéresse
voilà merci beaucoup